[Music]
okay
my name is george mohs and i've eaten
more burgers and more places than you
have that's right it's just pure math
and i get to pass that knowledge on to
you in the third installment of the
topping speed round let's do this four
regular everyday burgers with an
extraordinary topping on it two things
you'd never think to put on a burger
fluff and cashews and two things that
sound really good on a burger goop and
deep fried bacon these toppings
specifically make these burgers very
special very unique and very american
[Music]
sorry
today i have four regional toppings for
your smash burgers
the cashew burger from wisconsin coop
sauce from the pacific northwest the
fluff screamer from pennsylvania the
country fried bacon jalapeno
cheeseburger from texas let's do this
first up the cashew burger let's have
some fun with hot nuts ready for this
this is an old burger this burger's been
on the menu for almost 50 years at one
place the anchor bar in superior
wisconsin and because it's in the
shipping town of superior wisconsin the
cashew burger is simply a swiss
cheeseburger with grilled onions and
cashews on it it was the current owner's
father who invented the cashier burger
they were sitting at the bar one day and
he said i'd sure like to have some nuts
on my burger do we have any cashews
and that's how it happened just like
that
okay it's a i'm using
that's not hot enough
ball of beef starters
there we go okay salt like we need salt
give it a good smash now very important
what happens next is pretty cool at the
anchor bar they just take a handful of
handful of cashews
and put them right on the griddle next
to the burger you need a toasted bun
also so imagine what's happening here
you've got fat rendering out of the
burger right now right and it's kind of
co-mingling with our hot nuts
so good right two slices of swiss cheese
on top of that grilled onion okay i'm
gonna burn my nuts
burger patties done
that's a gorgeous looking burger on top
go the nuts now i don't know how we got
that
they're on the top of the damn thing
oh hot nuts ah yo
[Music]
end crown
there it is it's the cashew burger sorry
there it is the cashew burger from
anchor bar in superior wisconsin
they give you a side of nuts
you
oh okay oh hot nuts hot stuff yo
[Applause]
oh my god
the nuts are like little fire bombs
oh wow
oh swiss cheese
swiss cheese and underrated
burger cheese wow wisconsin no stranger
to regional oddities including this the
cashier burger
on to the next
goop sauce you know what goop is you
don't yeah don't think of gwyneth
paltrow
goop is a mainstay of hamburgers in the
pacific northwest it's a very curious
combination of mayonnaise sour cream
sweet relish and
mustard of course and that's it but one
guy chuck fritch from east side big tom
and olympia washington apparently has
the name trademarked sorry gwyneth
goop places like clark's way out in the
middle of woods in washington helvetia
tavern outside of portland and even the
very famous dicks as their own dick
sauce i can't say that
let's make a burger with goop add
toasty mud
hey
when you make goop it should have a
color of like a pale yellow
it should taste
tangy and mustardy at the same time
with sweetness it's the sugar in there
that actually does
balance the sauce perfectly that's why
it's so brilliant yeah
cheese on the flip oh
but they do it feast that big tom they
dope the bun get it ready
shredded
diced iceberg lettuce goop sauce on top
of that pickles
slice of tomato
double patties on top of that
oh yeah look at that thing
it's almost a perfect rendition
of a double
cheeseburger with goop from east side
big tom in olympia washington
i think chuck frisch should be proud of
me oh that's just too hot to eat
we gotta go we're late
that's all you need right there that's
it oh man
um
because of the sour cream
it's got a great tang to it i'm wearing
it
that is so good but we have more to do
on to the next oh man i'm gonna put it
down though
burger number three
the fluff screamer that's right i said
fluff i mean laugh bluff you know fluff
is you know fluff is
fluff
it's basically liquid marshmallow ah
i only know of one burger
that has fluff on it
it's the fluff screamer and it can be
found in the heart of coal country in
the middle of pennsylvania that's right
it's a burger with a screamin hot chili
sauce and marshmallow fluff it sounds
crazy actually it is crazy it's made
famous at a place called tony's lunch in
gerardville pennsylvania a burger with
fluff hot chili paste butter and
unmelted white american cheese
only in america people only in america
quarter pound petty
salt on there because we like to salt
our balls
burger flicking flippin
i could have made my own screamer sauce
for this segment but instead we went all
the way we actually had shipped in the
real deal
from a place called pops in mount carmel
and apparently pops is part of the
tony's legacy there's some family member
or something in there so i'm assuming
that this screamer sauce
is similar
to what goes on to tony's but not the
same this one has ground up hot dogs in
it
go cold country
that's
that's screaming hot
wow
on the other side of the bun the crown
of the bun we're gonna put first a
little bit of butter then the fluff the
patty goes on to the untoasted white bun
two slices
of white american cheese they folded
then they put the screamer sauce
on top of the cheese
that's some chopped onions on top of
that here this is really turning into a
oh a gastric experiment here okay and
then the crown of the bun which has
already been doped with fluff and butter
let's give it a shot
okay
good night
[Music]
oh oh
oh
uh-huh
yeah
wow
that is crazy
crazy that's crazy hot too oh wait a
minute
the fluff kind of balances out that heat
this burger is totally pushing the
boundaries this really it really is i
mean obviously but
i appreciate that i appreciate those who
take a chance
and then sell tons of them and they have
been for many many years they're doing
something right on to the next burger
number four the country fried bacon
jalapeno cheeseburger from texas yes
this is the brainchild of a good friend
of mine steve christian from christian's
tailgate in houston texas steve was
famous for putting bacon on his already
glorious jalapeno double cheeseburger
the big texas
two-fister yo
he got the idea from the houston rodeo
he saw people walking around with
deep-fried bacon on a stick and said hey
that belongs in my burger
and the rest is history first the bacon
so first we need a spoon [ __ ] i'm gonna
take some flour we're gonna make a
batter
lots of testing went into this it's
seasoned salt he also put some fresh
ground pepper in there gets whisked
together
then one slice at a time dredge that in
our mixture of flour
okay
it goes into
into the buttermilk
right
back into the flour mixture okay
and it goes into the oil you ready
it actually works oh is it working is it
working yeah
work for me work for me look at that
you see what it looks like
i'm sorry
that looks good there you go
it smells so good
oh my goodness whoo
yes
get a damn yankee making some deep fried
bacon leave it to the texan
oh
[Music]
yeah
yeah i win
okay burger time
half pound texas two fister
starts with a ball of beef
half pound
and you're toasting a bun
thank you
cheese on the flip
meanwhile we can dump the bun get the
bun ready mayonnaise on the bottom
perfect
yeah yeah yeah deep fried bacon on top
got some pickles on here tomato
some lettuce here we got a slice of raw
onion and most importantly the pickled
jalapenos on top of this
and of course the crown
now this looks totally insane and true
to texas form we're gonna wrap this
thing up
and waxed paper
look at that
it's pretty accurate that right there
it's a
texas two-fister see i got two fists on
this baby huh
um
oh my god hot wow
jalapenos are hot
they're hot
they're good
what
i don't have a texas sized mouth to get
it in there
i'm working
what's happening ah
there you have it
four toppings for you to try on your
smash burgers at home
because who doesn't want to have some
fluff jalapenos fried bacon
[Music]
screamer sauce
and goop on your burger
that's a wrap on season four thank you
so much for coming along for the ride
thanks for being here
you make it great i just make it weird
and goofy
yeah
we also get out there go out and eat the
burgers i'm talking about go to the
places and make sure that you say
thank you to the people who make them
give them a reason to make another
burger and stay open another day another
year another decade of a century
thanks very much everybody
hi i'm george moats from burger scholar
sessions don't forget to like and
subscribe and watch more episodes right
here
somewhere here
right here
up in here